cuando los humanos se comunican unos con
otros recurren a algunas herramientas
primero que nada recurren a un lenguaje
estamos acostumbrados a comunicar
nuestras ideas pensamientos y
sentimientos y también respondemos a las
ideas pensamientos y sentimientos de los
otros también utilizamos bastantes
señales
no ver a lis
sonreímos cuando estamos felices y
fruncimos el ceño cuando estamos tristes
podemos distinguir si algunas personas a
nuestro alrededor están ansiosas o
enojadas y también utilizamos
señales
sexuales
si pinto todas las habitaciones en mi
casa de negro y escucho todo el día
metálica a todo volumen estaré enviando
diferentes señales diferentes pistas de
mí misma que se pintará todos los
cuartos en mi casa de rosa y cubriera
todo con pósters de bailarinas y
unicornios
y otros animales
además de los humanos también tienen
formas de comunicarse tal vez no con un
lenguaje sino con muchas otras
diferentes señales no verbales y
visuales así como muchas otras formas de
comunicación que no son usadas por
humanos vamos a ver todas estas
diferentes formas de comunicación en
otro vídeo pero ahora me gustaría
tomarme un poco de tiempo para hablar de
por qué se comunican los animales y de
por qué esto es necesario una pregunta
que quizá uno quiere hacer es con quién
se comunican los animales algunas
especies de animales podrían usar
diferentes tipos de vocalización para
comunicarse con miembros de la misma
especie
pero los animales también pueden
comunicarse con otros animales que no
son de su misma especie
por ejemplo algunos tipos de ranas usan
colores brillantes para señalar que son
tóxicas lo cual permite a otros animales
saber que no se comen y por supuesto los
animales también se pueden comunicar con
los
humanos
todas las mañanas mis gatos me hacen
saber cuando es tiempo de despertar y
alimentarlos o por lo menos cuando ellos
creen que debería despertarme y
alimentarlos
pero también hay auto comunicación'
los animales también pueden utilizar la
comunicación para dar información a
ellos mismos y esa es un poco confusa
pero creo que el mejor ejemplo serían
los murciélagos y la
o localización
los murciélagos envían una señal y luego
la señal se refleja y regresa para
obtener información de las cosas que
están en su entorno bien los animales
pueden utilizar la comunicación para
darse información a sí mismos a miembros
de su misma especie oa miembros de otras
especies qué tipo de información tratan
de dar estos animales cuál es la función
principal
de la comunicación en los animales bueno
la primera podría ser los rituales de
apareamiento los animales pueden
producir una multitud de señales como
una forma de atraer
al sexo opuesto
algunos tienen colores muy brillantes
otros hacen danzas muy complicadas y
algunos usan llamados verbales
específicos los animales también
utilizan la comunicación
y proclamar
posición o territorio o para defender
territorio
básicamente es una forma de decirle a
otros animales que se aparten tuve
pájaros como mascotas en mi casa cuando
estaba creciendo y mis pájaros eran
extremadamente cariñosos se paraban en
tu hombro e intentaban comer toda tu
comida y en general eran bastante
sociables pero cuando pusieron huevos se
volvieron muy territoriales
quiero decir básicamente intentaban
desprenderte el dedo si te acercabas
demasiado a ellos
otra función de la comunicación en los
animales en la comunicación de fuentes
de alimento que consiste en señalar
a otros animales
donde pueden encontrar comida
también hay llamados de alarma en los
casos donde los animales intentan
prevenir
a los otros
de la presencia de un depredador
los animales también pueden utilizar la
comunicación como una forma para
establecer dominio
su misión
por ejemplo después de una pelea de
perros podrían adoptar diferentes
posturas para indicar quién resultó
victorioso
pero una de las cosas que quiero
asegurarme de decir antes de que
realmente empecemos a hablar de todas
las diferentes formas que los animales
pueden utilizar para comunicarse y
quiero decir que está claro que los
animales se comunican uno con el otro y
con nosotros como humanos pero tenemos
que ser muy cuidadosos en no pensar esto
demasiado tenemos que tener cuidado en
no
antro o por fijar
en no atribuir demasiadas
características humanas a animales no
humanos así que podemos intentar
interpretar intentar atribuirse ni fica
2 a las acciones de los animales pero
nunca podemos asegurar que estamos en lo
correcto porque no podemos preguntar a
los animales realmente a qué se refieren
mis gatos se duermen conmigo en la noche
y por lo regular se sientan conmigo
cuando estoy en el sillón y me gusta
suponer que es porque me aman y quieren
estar conmigo pero también es posible
que únicamente quieran mantener contacto
físico conmigo porque produzco mucho
calor corporal y entonces es más bien
esa motivación más que el amor lo que
explica los comportamientos de mis gatos